billions of people worldwide have been
vaccinated against covid-19
but dozens of research teams are still
working on more coronavirus vaccines why
in a word evolution
the first covid-19 vaccines protected
against SARS cov2 the original version
of the virus that emerged in 2019
but as new covid variants evolved the
protection provided by the original
vaccines did not
while some immune cells like B cells can
mature and develop to some extent the
antibodies they produce after exposure
to early vaccines still struggle to
latch on to newer variants like Omicron
and that contributes to a higher risk of
infection
and so researchers are developing a
whole host of Next Generation vaccines
in the endless race to stay one step
ahead
one approach is to update and combine
vaccines
companies like moderna Pfizer and
bioentec have already started to
introduce new bivalent mRNA vaccines
designed to Target both the original
version of the virus and the new Omicron
variants
these boosters encode molecules from the
original and Omicron Spike proteins the
goal is to retrain existing B cells as
well as stimulate the creation of new B
cells all in the hopes of producing
antibodies that bind more tightly to the
newer variants although as of yet it's
unclear how much of a difference this
will make
this approach is also being used to
create combination vaccines which could
protect against covert variants as well
as other diseases like influenza
while potentially helpful updating
covered vaccines in this way will always
be a step or two behind the virus and so
scientists also want to develop broadly
protective vaccines that can Target
future variants and even related
coronaviruses before they arise
one way to do this is by creating a
vaccine that targets parts of the virus
that don't tend to mutate currently most
covid-19 vaccines are based on the spike
protein but several groups are now
focusing more specifically on the part
of Spike which binds to human cells the
receptor binding domain or RBD
now the RBD contains some regions which
mutate relatively little between covert
variants and are even conserved in
certain related coronaviruses what's
more researchers can pepper vaccine
particles with many different rbds from
a whole host of covid variants and close
relatives
this is called a mosaic vaccine
to train antibody producing B cells you
want them to bind to your vaccine
particle and those that bind more
strongly are more likely to replicate
and flourish
in the case of this Mosaic vaccine the
strength of The Binding relates to how
many rbds the B cell can latch onto the
theory therefore is that B cells that
can only latch onto one or two specific
rbds won't bind strongly enough to
replicate
but the B cells that flourish will be
those that can bind to many rbds and the
reason they'll be able to do that is
they can recognize the regions that are
shared between them in effect you end up
with an immune response that sees past
the variation and focuses on the shared
broad features of these viruses
clinical trials are due to start in the
next two years
while spike is the most potent Target
for B cells it's not the only vaccine
Target for the immune system for example
T cells that destroy infected cells can
recognize many other viral proteins and
scientists are hoping to create vaccines
that capitalize on this using proteins
such as off-3a nucleoproteins or
membrane proteins this could better
mimic a natural infection only far more
safely
several of these vaccines are in late
stage trials
and there's more currently there are
four different types of covid-19 vaccine
known as platforms which have been
approved for use
but next Generation vaccines could
include updates to these designs first
mRNA mRNA vaccines helped turn the tide
of the pandemic particularly in
wealthier countries where the vast
majority of doses have been sold
but a Twist on this technology might
make vaccines cheaper more potent and
even reduce side effects mRNA vaccines
contain instructions for our bodies to
create a modified version of spiked
packaged in a fatty nanoparticle but new
generations of mRNA vaccines might also
include instructions for a replicase
protein which can tell cells to churn
out more copies of Spike this means that
a smaller dose of these self-amplifying
RNA vaccines could potentially induce
the same or an even stronger immune
response whilst simultaneously being
cheaper and reducing side effects
protein-based vaccines are also in for
an update typically these vaccines are
based on a single protein like Spike
which stimulates the immune system but
now in a new class of vaccine
researchers are building nanoparticles
using self-assembling proteins which can
then be studied with things like Spike
or RBD
the Mosaic vaccine we discussed earlier
is an example of this the repetitive
arrangement of the viral molecules in
these vaccines mimics the actual virus
and its hope that it will generate an
especially potent response
and it isn't just the platforms that
could see an overhaul new delivery
methods are also on the horizon for
example nasal vaccines which are inhaled
as a Mist through the nose or mouth or
administered as nasal drops by prompting
an immune response where the coronavirus
enters the body the thin mucous
membranes that line the nose and mouth
these vaccines could in theory stop the
virus before it spreads helping further
interrupt transmission not to mention
being much simpler to administer
there's a lot of innovation on the
horizon but in a crowded Market all of
these new vaccines face the same key
Challenge and that's proving they offer
genuine improvements over the existing
Jabs and that's not as easy as you might
think many of them will try to focus on
new selling points like further reducing
transmission of covid or treating
multiple infections such as covid and
flu
but with over 50 vaccines already
approved and hundreds more actively in
clinical trials new vaccines will really
have to stand out to make an impact
foreign